We may not have everything
we want at the moment,
but we do have each other.
Happy Valentine's Day.
Let's get down to business,
where are the brothers?
Kenya thought she knew exactly
what she wanted in a man.
He doesn't have to
make a lot of money,
so long as he's got a
job, no kids, good teeth.
He just has to be taller
than me, college educated,
and not crazy, or bisexual.
With her busy life--
You're being
considered for partner.
Some of us have to work extra
hard just to stay in the game.
--she didn't think
she'd ever find it.
Your house is amazing.
I love the landscaping.
Then you must meet
our landscaper.
Until she met someone new.
Kenya just bought
her first house.
Really?
So maybe you could
go take a look at it.
You'll have to leave
him in the car.
I don't do dogs.
Well, neither do I.
We're just good friends.
00:00:51,253 --> 00:00:52,920
You didn't tell me
you were landscaping.
Brian, this is my
baby brother Nelson.
What's happening?
Nelson.
It's the help.
[MUSIC - NATASHA BEDINGFIELD,
"THESE WORDS"]
(SINGING) I tried to
focus my attention.
You're coming with me.
We're going hiking.
Are you asking me out on a date?
I don't even like hiking--
--or dogs.
There's a whole list.
You have no idea.
[THUNDER RUMBLING, RAIN FALLING]
My hair!
(SINGING) Trying
to find the magic.
Don't think this is going
any further because it's not.
You did what?
With who?
For Kenny?
Yes.
Admit it, girl,
you're having fun.
I can tell.
Now all her worst fears--
Are you sneaking off to the OC?
--and all her closest family--
What on Earth has
gotten into you?
Are you skiing the slopes?
Do not answer that.
--are giving her
second thoughts.
I found your future husband.
This is for allowing
me to crash your party.
He's your ideal
Black man, and if you
don't know what to do with
him, girl, pass him on to me.
I can give him a load of babies.
Black, ashy babies.
Focus Features presents Sanaa
Lathan, Simon Baker, Mike Epps,
Donald Faison, Blair Underwood,
Golden Brooks, Taraji P Henson,
and Alfre Woodard.
You ought to feel real
blessed that you even invited
to this Negro spiritual.
Experience the most irresistible
romantic comedy of the year.
What's going on with you Kenny?
You got a man?
You seeing and somebody?
You got to listen
to your instincts.
Yeah, but what if my
instincts are screwed up?
Something New.
Hello, everyone.
My name is Jacqueline
Coley and I
am delighted to moderate this
conversation with The Academy's
Visiting Artist series.
The person we're
speaking with today
has an incredible, and
enviable, filmography.
So, without further ado, please
allow me to welcome our guest
today, Sanaa Hamri.
How are you, ma'am?
I'm good, I'm good.
Thanks for having me.
That clip was such a great
way to start this conversation
because it took me back
to watching this film--
which I saw in the theater--
because that trailer
just hooked me in the way
it did the first time I saw it.
I don't know what trailer I
saw it for but I was like,
yes I need to see this film.
It has all of my
absolute favorite people
and it's just an
incredible thing.
What is it like watching
that trailer again?
Did it feel like you're
going back in time?
It's interesting.
I definitely felt like I
was going back in time,
but I felt like it held up
with what is going on today.
And I love the fact
that the movie still--
Something New-- still holds up.
And I love all those
actors, and I was just
thinking how amazing
they did and how
it's just a fun, fun movie.
Yeah, no, it's one of, I think,
several incredible romantic and
friendship-driven movies that
are part of your filmography.
And we're definitely
going to discuss them
as we talk about your
career and your work.
But we're going to
kind of take it back
because, as I said
in my introduction,
you have an enviable
filmography.
And it started
from the beginning
of being enviable because
you started literally
with Queen Mariah.
Directing her in your very first
credit, which, let's just say,
by that point I would have
given up and like, this is it.
There's nothing going
to top directing Mariah.
So talk about starting
off in music videos, how
you got that first credit, which
I know so many folks watching
this can think back to or
maybe of thinking towards.
Well, I started
off as an editor.
And I was editing a lot
of the cheaper rap videos,
like hip hop videos.
And then I had a small
career of just learning
a lot about music.
And it was through
kind of the eyes
of the rappers of the time.
And I met Mariah as
an editor because one
of the editors, the really
famous, go-to editor
was not available.
So I wound up having
to step in and edit
for Hype Williams at the time.
And she walked in
the editing room
and she had never
seen a woman of color.
You know, at that
time, I was way young.
And usually it was a
certain type of person
who would be behind
that Avid machine.
So she was very
curious about me.
I knew a little bit
about her music.
But I grew up in
Morocco, so I wasn't as
familiar with certain things.
So you know, we slowly
got to know each other
through the editing bay.
And it was her idea
for me to direct.
And I really wasn't.
I was like, I went
to theater school.
I went to Sarah Lawrence and
studied theater and psychology.
So I never went to film school.
I'm self-taught as an editor.
And when she suggested
that I should direct
one of her videos, I
literally was like, Mariah,
I don't want to
screw up the video.
I've never directed before.
And she's like, Sanaa,
I see your vision.
I see your eye.
And she was like, I've worked
with a lot of directors
and I know you can do this.
So I really trusted her.
And I did my first
video with her,
which was the Thank God I Found
You remix video with Joe & Nas.
And it became like
the number one video.
And back in the day, they
would put our names on it.
So people were like, yo,
you're a music video director.
And I'm like, oh, I don't know.
I was like, I'm still an editor.
It was a one-off.
And then a lot of the other
artists started calling me,
like Destiny's Child,
Jay-Z. And they're like,
can you do a video?
We know you're an editor.
But could you do a video for us?
And I'm like, OK,
I'll do one more.
And then, all of a sudden, I
became a music video director.
And I still edited all my stuff.
Nobody called me
anymore for editing jobs
because I was competing with the
directors that were hiring me.
And so I learned a lot
through Mariah's eyes, well,
she is very astute to what's
a great looking shot, fashion,
all of that world that I
actually never knew about.
I knew more about
Moliere and Shakespeare
versus who is the hottest
fashion designer at that time.
So I kind got to learn that.
And then she took
me on tour with her.
And you know,
directing tours, it's
a whole other kind of
thing in the wheelhouse.
And I mean, I just
really-- it was boot camp.
I really learned a
lot about filmmaking.
Because when you're working
with an artist like Mariah,
you're using really high
level cinematographers.
So I literally was a
student of these DPs
in learning about lighting, and
just what with the great lens
is.
So I've been very fortunate
in terms of my schooling
as a filmmaker there with her.
And I love hearing
you talk about her.
As someone who's just
been a fan of her music
and obviously just
seeing her from afar,
I love how she saw something
in another female artist.
And with the position that
she's in, she's Mariah Carey.
If she says, this
is the person I
want to direct the
music video, you're
the person directing
the music video.
And I think that is
so essential, I think,
when we talk about how
Hollywood is going to change.
It's her seeing you in that
edit bay which then just keeps
that thing going to where
young filmmakers or just people
like myself who wanted
to write about movies,
seeing a movie like
yours and being like,
this is the type of
movie that I want
to talk about and write about.
And I love how that's the
cyclical fashion of filmmaking.
But Mariah wasn't the first,
and she wasn't the last,
I would say, in your just
incredibly storied music
career.
But music videos,
it's interesting
that you mention that.
Because I think it breeds
incredible independent film
directors because you are
on very tight timelines.
You are usually with
not budgets that
are as friendly as
the visuals they
would like to see upon them.
And so I'm just curious.
You said that it
was a boot camp.
What is something that you
learned during that time
that you specifically still
think about when you're
approaching some of
your features like Just
Right or Sisterhood of
the Traveling Pants 2?
I think the music
video realm really
teaches you how to work
under pressure and quickly.
It is kind of synonymous
with filmmaking, I would say.
Because a lot of
times, with budgets
and in all of those
things, you have
to be able to think
really quick on your feet
and give a really great product.
And I think the
music video realm,
you know, we get booked on
jobs like three days before.
You get a call and it's like,
Jay-Z wants to film wherever.
Are you available?
Or Puffy, or whoever
it is at the time.
And you have to
think quick and you
have to deliver the product.
So I feel like
that kind of hones
you for that energy that
you bring to the table
when you're filming.
And also, I solve
a lot of problems
that are creative
problems when I'm on set.
I can look at something and
then all of a sudden I'm like,
oh, this is not working.
Like, I know it's not working
and I just immediately pivot.
Like, no fear is the key.
You have to be able to
look at something, say, no,
that's not going to work.
I'm pivoting.
We're going to do it this
way, and do it in the time
so that you make your
days and all that.
So I definitely
find the music video
training is guerrilla style.
And you're also dealing
with the music industry.
And how can I say this?
But the music
industry is a mishmash
of people that come
from all walks of life.
And you can deal with
people who are lawyers
down to drug dealers.
So you have to really be
able to handle people.
And entourages, and
artists' entourages,
and artists feeling
a certain way.
So I think it's such
a heightened melting
pot of the best of what could
go in filmmaking and the worst.
Yeah.
I think that it's a
crucible, like you said.
And what comes out of it is
these incredible filmmakers.
And I especially
love when I speak
to filmmakers, or artists,
or creatives like yourself
that come from
different backgrounds.
One of my favorite film
composers, you know,
he's a classically
trained pianist.
But he also was very much in
depth into hip-hop culture
and was in an
instrumental hip hop band.
I'm talking about the Oscar
nominated composer Nicholas
Britell.
And just seeing him and
how he works with Pusher
to do a remix for the stuff
that he does with succession.
And I think those sort of
different, I would say,
influences really bring into it.
So I'm just curious.
Obviously, theater
is a medium where
there's a lot of crossover.
But back to your
Sarah Lawrence days,
I think there's just definitely
something about your time there
that is something that is
not maybe necessarily seen
in a lot of folks that
are in a director's chair
that you could sort
of meld into that.
Did you see that
when you were first,
I would say, directing
music videos,
but more definitely
with the features?
Well, I think when I was
on the set of Something New
and I was finally directing
actors with dialogue,
I realized what that Sarah
Lawrence College training
was in theater brought to me.
Because I was able to--
I was trained in Alexander
Technique and all of the stuff
that actors have to do to
open up their instrument, make
them feel comfortable.
And I was not really using it
when I was doing music videos
and commercials.
I only finally was able to
use it in my first feature.
And right on the set
of Something New,
I realized this is where
I'm supposed to be.
The music video thing felt
very transitory and more
like I was going to grad school.
[LAUGHS] And then, on the
set of Something New I said,
oh, I'm a full
fledged film director.
And I always felt like
I had a lot to say.
And that's why the music
video format for me
was kind of stifling
because I wanted
to tell so much of a story and
always have a point of view.
What I consciously did before
I did my first film was I
only did music videos where
I felt like had a purpose.
Here and there I did a video,
like I did a Nicki Minaj video
or whatever.
But mainly, I wanted
to uplift the vision
of people of color and women
in music video pop culture.
And I figured I had a voice.
So I was doing that.
But then I felt like I needed
to do that in a larger format
to be able to
really tell a story.
So, Something New.
At that point, I go, OK,
this is where I'm headed.
And I have a lot to say.
And I and I want to always
bring a point of view.
Entertain, but at
the same time not
have caricatureish
cliched characters
that have been perpetuated
for a long time.
So those things matter to me.
And you did it.
You're correct on your
very first feature.
And it's so funny that you
say that your music video
days and that time in commercial
work was like grad school.
Because I'm like, if
your grad school includes
Prince, and Jay-Z, and Christina
Aguilera, and Mariah Carey,
that's the grad school
I would like to go to.
But let's talk about
that graduation process.
Because as I talk to
a lot of filmmakers
who have moved from commercial
work or music videos,
there is a bit of
a glass ceiling
there where, although
you have this
maybe I would say storied
career within the medium,
obviously you know
how to direct.
But getting someone
to say, hey, we're
going to trust you to sort of
jump into this next level is
sometimes very
difficult for folks
to get that level of trust
from producers, or actors,
or everyone.
So how did the script--
I mean, how did Something New,
the whole process come to you?
And then, that cast as well.
Because that is
just an incredible
cast to have on your
very first feature.
I mean, Sanaa Lathan,
which, first of all,
give it up for
everyone on that crew,
making sure they get
your two names correct.
[LAUGHS] And then also--
It was rough.
--Simon Baker.
I know.
It was rough.
We kept turning every time.
I said, I'm going
to call you Kenya.
You're Kenya on set.
I'm Sanaa.
And she's just, I got it.
I got it.
Kenya, Sanaa.
I still think people
would mix that up.
And Simon, and Donald, and Alfre
Woodard, and Blair Underwood.
But yeah, talk about taking that
step to your very first feature
film, which was incredible.
Incredible film.
Well, just like the sisterhood
that Mariah and I had--
and it takes real,
true sisterhood--
the other sisterhood
was Stephanie Allain
who produced Something New
who took a chance on me.
And at that time,
if you think of it,
people like me were
not around like now.
Now, everybody, thankfully.
Way overdue.
But I mean, I would
walk into rooms
and I mean, it
would really ruffle
feathers just the way I looked,
the fact that I was a female,
that I was mixed,
that they didn't know
what, they didn't know how.
I mean, all of that stuff,
I'm very conscious of it.
And I'm confident in who I am.
I have to be.
But it took a sisterhood.
And it took Stephanie Allain.
We had a conversation.
I didn't even know how
to meet on a script.
Like, I read the script
and I really loved it,
but I had some notes.
And I talked to
Stephanie about it.
And I said, look, I
really want to add this.
The scene with the
hair with them in bed
was something that I kind of
thought up and told the writer,
I want us to tackle
those things.
I know it's
uncomfortable for us,
but we need to talk about
these things, especially--
He's like, well,
do you sew it in?
And making Kenya feeling
uncomfortable about
that she has a
sew-in, and all that.
Boy, back in the
day, people weren't
talking about that stuff.
So it took that.
It's important that
women and women of color
take the leap of
faith with each other.
And that's what it took.
See, had Mariah not
said I could direct,
and Stephanie Allain didn't
give me my first feature.
And of course,
Focus approved it.
But Stephanie, she made sure
it happened, and she got me.
And that's how I was able
to kind of jump in it.
It wasn't an easy
road after that,
let's be clear,
because we're still
dealing with all that stuff.
But it's way better now.
Everything is as it should be.
That's how I view life.
So I'm not in resistance.
I'm always continuing
excellence, and continuing
the legacy of women,
of people from Africa,
and all women of color
all over the world.
So that's how I
view those things.
So that was kind of like that
jumping into something new.
And doing my first
feature felt really good.
The actors were so
respectful and great.
They actually knew my music
video work at that time.
So I wasn't like
an unknown entity,
it just was my first feature.
And you know, I
learned a lot on it.
But I also felt comfortable.
I knew that was my calling.
That to me really mattered.
And I loved working
with a diverse group
of people with different
point of views, different all
of that.
And I actually made the
characters- Sometimes
one of the characters, I don't
know it was Donald Faison.
But somebody was
like, man, are we
going too hard on the white boy?
I was like, no.
I was like, we have to.
If you've been in an
interracial relationship,
you know that it is not hard.
He got about right.
And then Mike Epps was like, yo.
I remember Mike
pulling me aside.
He said, I think I'm going
to be alienating my fans.
I was like, we don't
care about that, Mike.
I was like, we have to do this.
He goes, all right.
He goes, Sanaa, all right.
And back then, I
mean, you couldn't.
And I was like, keep
going, because they
improved a lot of this stuff.
And I think it's a fun movie.
We're not trying to--
but it kind of
helped frame a future
because I believe
that images are things
and it does sway the future.
And I want to sway it
in the good direction.
So to me it's like
that was that piece
that helped sway us for
self-acceptance and being open
minded.
Because the fact
of the matter is,
I was Kenya's character--
not as open minded.
I hadn't dated a white boy.
That's what I related to.
And I came up with all the
reasons why I felt that.
And then Blair
Underwood character
was the brother who was
actually a good guy,
but he wanted a
certain type of woman.
He didn't see her.
For folks that haven't
seen the film--
He didn't see her.
Sanaa Lathan's character
goes on a bit of a journey
to not just embrace who she
is by having her natural hair,
but by saying who she is.
She's a very high
powered Black woman,
which is actually
something people
are talking about more now.
Black women are one of
the most high, as far as
per capita, at high
levels of education,
high levels of achievement.
And then the dating
situation around that
is quite precarious,
particularly
when certain people
judge you a certain way
if you date somebody
outside of your race.
And this film not only
brought a light to that,
but tackled it in
a way that was just
filled with such authenticity.
And I think there were so
many moments within that.
But I was just normalizing
the difference between women
wearing a sew-in versus
wearing their natural hair,
normalizing the conversations
that you would actually have
with your female friends if this
was the first person outside
of your race that
you were dating,
normalizing being a Black
woman in corporate America
and realizing the double
standards of that existence--
the twice as hard
to get half as much.
All of these things are things
that folks talk about now.
But this was not something that
folks were seeing on TV shows.
And I think you can make
a direct correlation
between seeing Issa Rae wearing
a head wrap to bed in Insecure
and some of the stuff
that you guys talked
about with Something
New, which is incredible.
But we're not going to just
talk about Something New
because obviously this is just
the beginning of what you said.
But you touched
on something, too.
Sundance had this
incredible statistic
that Barry said a few
years ago that they had,
I think it was 50%
of the films that
were at the Sundance
Film Festival
were directed by women.
But the years between
a woman debuting
at Sundance and
her second feature,
or any debut from
a female director
and their second feature
is sometimes years.
And sometimes it's
the second movie
that's the hardest one
to get, in a lot of ways.
And so, talk about
that journey for you.
Because I can guess based
on just this conversation,
but also just based
on what I know
talking to female filmmakers,
that was another battle--
another moment to sort
of prove that you're
going to continue on this path.
Right.
So obviously you think when
you do your first film--
which is usually the case
for the men who do do that--
they wind up like, if it was
a guy who did Something New,
he would have done
Batman, the next one.
Like, it goes automatically
and really quick.
That's just the truth.
I'm not mad at him.
I want everybody
to be successful.
But I'm just talking math.
So it's clearly always
an uphill battle.
Only until recently this
past year that you feel,
oh, like, wow.
Like, it's shifted,
which is, thank God.
But I was always used
to that uphill battle.
And I always say, it's the
survival of the fittest.
It's not a sprint,
it's a marathon.
So I have that kind of fighter
mentality ingrained in me.
So getting to that
second feature
was really, really tough.
Because of course,
when they see you,
which is really
interesting process
that what you have on the
outside and your agenda
is going to determine if you're
capable of doing something
when clearly, we're
all very capable.
So it took a long time.
I wasn't up for a lot of movies.
But then let's talk about
the other Sisterhood again.
[VIDEO PLAYBACK]
[MUSIC PLAYING]
For as long as I could
remember, the four of us
shared everything.
[MUSIC PLAYING]
(SINGING) You were
always playing hard.
I believed that the sisterhood
could survive anything.
[GIGGLES]
(SINGING) That voice within.
But we had to learn on our
own how to become ourselves
without losing each other.
[YELPS]
(SINGING) Don't look
away, don't run away.
Baby--
Whoa!
(SINGING) --it's only life.
So the other sisterhood
is Debra Martin Chase,
who was the producer
of Traveling Pants.
So now we're starting
to see this correlation
in every single opportunity.
It was the Mariahs,
the Stephanie Allains,
and the Debra Martin
Chases of the world.
So Debra was the one who really
pushed them to consider me.
And Alcon was a really
great place for me, too,
because they're kind of
nontraditional and independent
guys.
You got Andrew and Broderick.
Broderick's Black,
Andrew's white.
You know, so it's a
different kind of vibe.
Debra really championed
me for the second film.
And then I wound up doing
a third movie with Debra.
And I think that really
made a difference,
is when you have a producer
who looks at you as a filmmaker
and doesn't genderize you
and doesn't color you.
Because I bring my
experience, my growing
up in Africa, all of those
things comes with it.
But at the same time, I
want the same opportunities.
And we should all give each
other the same opportunities.
I feel like Debra was really
key in continuing that motion.
And it wasn't easy then, too.
Even doing the movie wasn't
easy, and all of that stuff.
So after that film, too,
it was really difficult.
I was still dabbling.
While I was doing those movies,
I was still dabbling in music,
I have to be real.
I was working a lot with Prince.
I was his creative director.
That's what I was just going to.
[LAUGHS]
I was this creative
director for like, a decade.
And I kept working
with him on the side.
He was like my side gig.
And he would always say, man,
are you moonlighting again?
And I'm like, yeah.
I was like, I can't
do it this weekend,
but I could do it next weekend.
So literally, he was
my side gig while I
was trying to pursue this.
Prince was very--
he was with me.
He came with me as my guest to
the premiere of Something New.
And that was when he
first saw the film.
And he was like, it's
ahead of its time.
And then he was
very encouraging.
He knew what the battle was.
Remember, he did direct a movie
and he's been around Hollywood.
He knows what it takes.
00:27:20,690 --> 00:27:27,140
I think he was there to
encourage me and keep me going.
Like, yeah, you can do this.
But at the same
time, I could tell
at times he would feel for
me and know how the road kept
getting steeper and steeper
when it should have not
gotten steeper and steeper.
But again, I was born
and raised in Africa.
And when you have that
kind of upbringing,
an entire continent of I
look at as like my ancestors.
I was like, I am not giving up.
Like, I'm going to get there.
It can get as steep as--
I'll start climbing up
like this, whatever it is.
But you know, I've
had the great support.
So that was happening while
I was doing the other movie.
So what was good is I
didn't have to take work
that I didn't want to do.
And during that time,
I was interested in TV.
And I was like, man, I
want to have my own show.
So I was like, let me try
directing here and there.
Let me learn about this TV
industry, which was completely
different from film, completely
different from music videos,
different breed of
people, different culture,
different way
people do business.
I was like, man,
they have lunches,
they get their weekends off.
I was like, oh.
I was like, I've
got to get into--
Like literally,
because I was used
to filming on the
weekends a music video,
doing movies, and
then going on tour.
And then I said, wow, these TV
people, they have a good life.
[LAUGHS] So I just--
It's a good gig.
Good gig.
Good gig and content.
So I kind of went because
I mean, I'm a creator.
So I want to have my
own shows, and again
to have characters
that are authentic,
that represent the now.
Female characters not
being pawns and active
at the service of
male characters.
People of color being in
positions that we all are in,
and then seeing that and
seeing the trials, tribulations
of that.
So I feel like the meet--
entertainment in any form
is where we can make
a change in the world.
And that's all that matters
to me in anything that I do.
That's why I move
between mediums
because I'm like,
oh, if I can't,
let me try to reach this group.
Let me try to reach
the younger group.
I always try to stay in
the ear of the youth.
Gen Z, I study them so that I
can keep pushing that needle.
That's incredible.
And I wish more people
approached it the way you do,
as a student of, really, people.
Of sociology, really.
I mean, that's really
what you're doing.
And that I think
is why when I look
at so many of the characters
that you've directed,
from Queen Latifah's
character in Just Wright,
to the girls in Sisterhood
of the Traveling Pants,
to some of the stuff
you did with Empire
and some of the other shows,
they feel like real people.
They do not feel
like caricatures.
Even when they're doing these
very sort of broad things,
it still feels like
this is somebody
that I would know from around
the way, especially for me
when we get to Just Wright.
But I wanted to touch on real
quick with the Prince stuff
because he also seemed
to me to be, as you said,
sort of an artist's advocate and
just an advocate for creatives
being given the freedom to just
do, to just create, to just
make art.
And he always just
seemed to me anyone
who got a chance
to, like you did,
work with him intensely and sort
of learn at the side of him,
and also help him
craft his vision.
They all talk about
how just stunned
they were with his talent,
and the talent that
maybe even he was stunned by.
But more, they were
stunned by the fact
that he wanted to rise
everyone around him.
And I think you've already
talked on it a little bit.
But I just would imagine that
was another not an education,
but a different
sort of perspective
to how you could approach
filmmaking after that, too.
Absolutely.
I mean, Mariah gave me
the base, but he also
gave me the point of view.
And it was another school.
I went through his school.
And it's kind of like the
school of James Brown.
I mean, it's a different type
of [LAUGHS] a different type.
Basically, I was always
inherently musical.
Remember, I used to
edit images to music.
So I inherently have
music behind me.
He really got me up to his level
because I would edit for him,
I would film him.
When he would do
concerts and stuff,
rehearsal, all
the lighting cues.
You see, he knew about lighting
cues like nobody else did.
And I literally learned all
about the lighting cues.
He's like, was that late?
And meanwhile, it's
like a microsecond late.
And I'm like, yeah,
I think it was.
He goes, well, it can't be late.
So I would have to
time some of the cues.
So Prince gave me this
manual, tactile, sonic way
of approaching things.
So after going through his
school, I can hear everything.
And anything that's out of sync,
off beat or whatever, somebody
claps off-beat like you
see that, or dance off
beat or whatever, I catch
it before most people,
and it's because of him.
And we film so much
that a lot of stuff
is not out or
anything like that.
Like, I spent a lot of time
in the studio with him,
and Maceo Parker, and a
lot of different artists.
And being around
that live music,
and seeing it being
recorded, and just being
around that process
really taught me
a lot about filmmaking.
And it opened my mind visually
of what one can do, what works.
Seeing an image and
what does that sound.
So score is so important to me.
And he was so good
at making score.
He made a few pieces for me.
He was like, well,
what do you want?
I'm like, I want to
kind of like this.
And he's like, well, I'm
not making elevator music,
he'll say.
[LAUGHS] I was like, I
don't want elevator music.
But we don't need it.
Like, they're
eating in the cafe.
Like, we can't have a guitar
solo here, it's distracting.
But it was really good,
really good school.
And I'm so grateful for that.
Sound is part of filmmaking
and so important.
And the tones of sound
really can indicate a scene.
And I really learned a
lot from Prince on that.
I should have known a music
video director directed
Something New when you
open with that love song
because I literally bopped
to that song for, like, weeks
after I saw that.
And this was back
when you couldn't just
go to Spotify or Shazam.
I had to go back and be
like, what is this song?
I'm like, watching the credits
to pick it out of the credits
so I can go buy it later.
Again, tell a little bit my age.
But yeah, no.
And all of your movies, both
music cues and as well as
scoring, it drives things.
I think about the basketball
scenes in Just Wright
and how you guys set
up stuff with that.
It's the same thing.
We do have also some questions
from the students that
had submitted for you here.
And they definitely want
to definitely talk to you
about craft and technicality.
But before we get
there, I want to kind of
bring it to a full circle
moment because you're right.
You've done a ton of
incredible television.
But I thought the
television show obviously
that felt like such a
great full circle moment
is you directing on Empire
because I feel like it marries
the roots of your
filmmaking and even
very first feature
because you're reteaming with
Taraji who, if folks don't
know, her quote in
the trailer which
is like, I'm going to give
them black, ashy babies.
That is like, she's just so
incredible in that movie.
And I can imagine it
was kind of interesting
coming back to this now.
I mean, this is her show.
And coming back in to
direct, again, I just
feel like it had to be felt
like a bow on everything
that you've done thus far.
Absolutely.
When I was approached
with Empire
I was approached by Lee Daniels,
and Danny Strong, and Ilene
Chaiken.
And Lee hadn't done
television before.
And Lee Daniels
and I were talking.
And he was like, we
need somebody like you
because you've done a little
TV, but you get the vision
of the music industry.
And you'll be my ears and eyes.
And I was like, I love it.
I want to do it.
And it was my first
executive producer job,
and I directed a bunch.
But that was kind of like
my next phase in life
as being an executive
producer and understanding
how to do that in
television, which was
another part of the boot camp.
And seeing Taraji there and
kind of collaborating with her
on a different level was great.
Because Taraji, when I
put her in Something New,
she had just started.
And Stephanie Allain was the
one who told me about her.
And I looked at her tape
and I was like, I like her.
Let's put her in.
I like her authenticity.
So then, now she's
Cookie on Empire
and we spent so
much time together.
And that was almost
seven years of my life.
So I kind of disappeared up
in Chicago where we filmed it.
And you know, it was a really
good kind of full circle
moment for me because it took
place in the music industry,
which I knew.
It had a lot of drama and
music, it had fashion.
It had all of those elements
that I was in charge
of from the visual sense.
We had writers in LA, but
everything else was me.
And a great testament
to Lee Daniels and Danny
Strong for them trusting
me with continuing
the vision and kind of making
it my own thing as well.
I love that.
And yeah, when I was--
I obviously knew
some of your work.
But when I clocked on how
much you did with Empire,
I was like, you don't know the
job that you're essentially
learning how to do
when you get there.
But I feel like every
stop along the way
before Empire was
training you how
to do that incredible job that
we all saw for all those weeks
on television, like how
to do that at that level.
Because if folks don't
remember, Empire was a thing.
It was like, when
that came out I,
remember everybody's
like, you watching Cookie?
Are you watching this?
It was like it was such there.
And it has to have people
like you, and Lee, and Taraji,
and Terrence involved to
put that into the DNA of it.
And you can absolutely see it.
Absolutely.
And we were all film
people, which is great.
I learned a lot about
the TV industry.
But it really took film people,
that chemistry between us
and being like really excellent
at everything, and down
to the production design.
I mean, we were
matching wallpaper
to curtains we were in it
like a movie on every episode.
And it was a lot.
It was a lot to carry,
but well worth it.
Because I think Empire opened
up for a lot more content,
whether it was
movies or television,
with a diverse group of people.
How about that?
Yeah.
That looked--
Telling very authentic stories.
--like the world.
Yeah.
Not white-washed stories.
Completely within the culture.
Totally.
And you know, we have to have
those avenues because the world
doesn't look like one thing.
It has many faces that
should all be included.
So I'm very proud of that show.
I especially like
the part where you
talked about the
collaborative process of it.
And you've been
great in the sense
that you talk about
letting people go wrong.
But also-- and this is another
question from the folks
here-- is, sometimes you have
to push back as the person who's
got the 10,000 feet view.
And sometimes that's
with executives.
And so this question
is, as a director,
how do you go about getting
the approvals from studio
executives maybe
when they're saying,
we don't want to do this.
Like, how do you
thoughtfully push back?
Because I think that is as
big a part of the job as it
is to see the vision.
Because if you can't get
people to buy into it,
it's never going to happen.
OK, so this is where I start.
First, I'm not doing
a project with people
that don't mutually
kind of share
that end result.
So I always say,
when you place yourself in that
position, you're going to lose.
Because if you're thinking about
apples, and they want oranges,
and you're just
trying to get the gig
and say, OK, I'm going to do
an orange, then you get the gig
and then you're like, I'm doing
apples, then you're in a fight.
So I don't place myself
in those positions.
The studio, the execs
are my partners.
And when I go in, I look
to them to be partners.
And I'm very clear before
I even start the project,
this is what I'm going for.
And I do visual decks and stuff.
And then I hear their feedback.
And there could
be little things.
That kind of like,
oh, you know what?
We didn't see this
character like this.
She seems a little bit--
I'll ask questions.
Like, why do you feel that way?
What is it?
A lot of times,
the execs, it could
be a small tweak for me to do
but it sounds big for them.
And I think it's about
really being a good listener
and collaborative.
But if you just
start the project
as they're your partners, you're
already winning half the time.
So then it's like
the little things.
There are times in which
choices that are made they're
not understanding.
I've run into that.
I've run into a situation in
which a studio exec did not
understand the
concept of editing
because that person
thought that I did not
have the right shots,
which I knew I did.
Remember, I used
to be an editor.
But I'm not going to
lead with, I'm an editor,
I know I'm right.
No.
I had to cut the scene while
filming, which DGA-wise,
you don't have to do.
I'm protected.
But I chose to cut the scene as
a rough while I was shooting,
mind you.
And meanwhile, I should
cook for everybody--
Not an abundance of time to--
Right?
Yeah.
And [LAUGHS] I
should do all that.
And I sent the scene
in to the studio.
And then they called
apologizing to me.
But I'm a solution
oriented person,
so it's about
finding a solution.
I can't get bogged
down in why, who, why
are they feeling that way.
It just will not
help the situation.
And it is about kind of
a focus and a mentality
that I love talking
about with filmmakers
because that's half the battle.
Everybody is talented.
But it's, how are you dealing
with the interpersonal
back and forth with people?
So I mean, I have
a million stories.
That's just a nice sample.
I've had way worse stories that
we do not want to get into.
But I'm good for it.
But it's an example of how
I have to be a partner.
We have a couple more here.
And you actually kind of touched
on it, too, a little bit.
What are the first
questions you're
asking in that first
moment with the script?
Which I always
think is so great.
It's after the director
is given a script,
or maybe after they've
written a script.
It's that first moment,
from that moment
when they switch off the writer
brain to when they're then
into the director.
What are those first questions?
What are those first
sort of, I would say,
rabbit holes you're
going down to to find
the visual side of the story?
meaning I've already
accepted the script.
Yes.
Already accepted the
script, and now you're
like, what is that first
thinking about the characters,
the shot?
Like, what is those
first moments with it?
Well, each script is different.
I think the script and the
story and the characters
will tell you what it is.
Like, sometimes
I'm reading a scene
and I go, oh, I get the style.
This is going to be
handheld with kind
of like a voyeuristic
camera angle.
I start seeing those kind
of framings and energy
in terms of how to
capture the characters.
I think about that.
I also think about who's going
to play these characters.
I also want to make sure
that it all matters,
and that the characters
are super authentic,
and that we can
understand the story
from a different point of view.
So I mean, my process can vary.
But I definitely pull images.
I'll just scrounge around for
images from, like, photography
books.
I'm like, oh, this made me
think of like Shibuya and Tokyo
when I was there.
Let me pull this--
the crowdedness.
Like, I'm a little left of field
with the way I pull my images.
And then I start creating
these color palettes.
I'm very intent on what
the vibe is going to be.
And so it's not
all over the place.
And then, once I know what it
is, I land on it, so to speak.
I'll look for that.
I'm going to go a little
off script with this one.
But you mentioned
that in addition
to reading these
photography books and all
of that in your research,
you mentioned that you
watch a lot of foreign films.
I'm just going to, because
I'm curious as to what
I need to be watching next.
What are you watching?
What should I go pick up
if I maybe haven't seen it,
which I'm always excited to do.
Well, [LAUGHS] the foreign
films I watch are older movies.
So it's like
[SPEAKING FRENCH] which
is Last Year at Marienbad.
[SPEAKING FRENCH] is one
of my favorite films.
Another great film that
I love the energy of it
is Godard's Contempt,
[SPEAKING FRENCH]..
There's Cache, which is
more of a modern thing.
There's [SPEAKING FRENCH]
Cleo from 5 to 7.
Like, I watch a lot
of the classics.
Also, I've been watching
recently some horror.
There's a very scary
movie from France
called Martyrs, which is really
very interesting camerawork
and stuff that I study.
Like, I'll study different
things for different reasons--
lighting exposures
and lenses and stuff.
And then, of course, I'm
on Criterion all the time
and seeing what's there.
I watch a lot of
African films, too.
And I see what's
happening back home.
So that matters to me, too.
I love that.
I actually just
recently finally got
to see Ganja & Hess for the
first time, which I think
is just an incredible film.
And since you mentioned
French filmmaker and horror,
I'm just going to
go and say, if you
haven't seen Julia Decournau's
Raw, I live for that movie.
It is one of the most twisted
horror coming of age story
you'll ever see.
I live for it.
Oh, my God.
So [LAUGHS] I know that
was a bit of a detour.
But hey, we're at the Academy.
It's all about recommendations.
Totally.
The two words that will
make any film fan light up
is Criterion Collection.
[LAUGHING]
I know.
I mean, that's what
I do on my off time.
[LAUGHS]
Exactly.
Well, I just have to say this.
It was a real joy to
take a small peek back
at your incredible
filmography and all the work
that you've done.
I felt that I learned something.
I everyone listening to this.
So just thank you so
much for your time.
And I also want to
thank the Academy
for inviting us here to do this
because it was really a treat.
And I think it's just fun to
talk movies with movie people.
So thank you so much.
Thank you so much.
It was fun.